I think ultimately it's very hard for a
democracy to be to be of to declare it
to declare really only one legitimate
faith I think you know to return to what
we were talking about earlier I think
you can say we I mean I when I was in
Bangladesh a few a couple of months ago
and had talked to the Prime Minister
there and I said you know well this is
obviously a Muslim country and she said
to me I don't like you saying that she
said this is a country with a
predominantly Muslim population that's a
different thing and that distinction i
think is very very important so i doubt
it you know don't doubt you can
construct a hypothesis in which you have
a democracy with one religion being
regarded as superior to others but it's
quite hard to see that as a in practical
terms as a democracy that will function
and I also think and I think the second
is something that it was saying earlier
that there's something inherent in the
nature of democracy that there is a
pluralistic idea behind it and and
anything that militates against that
idea undermines the essential concept
and by the way it is always my
experience that a majority of people in
these countries despite what people say
actually completely understand that and
are far more tolerant than those who
shout loudest would have you believe